it was over in less than a week the
self-styled provisional government of
the Irish Republic surrendered and
Britain executed 16 of its leaders but
the Easter Rising of 1916 changed the
course of history
the failed rebellion and Britain's
response to it brought an urgency to the
demand for independence the relationship
between these islands would never be the
same again the first world war was
underway
200,000 Irishmen were fighting in the
British Army and taking heavy losses
across Europe no one anticipated an
uprising at home a lightly armed band
had seized Dublin's general post office
and declared Ireland an independent
republic Britain turned its military
might on the Irish capital and crushed
the rebellion in a few days but
Ireland's President Michael D Higgins
says it was a finding moment for the
nation if they had lasted near enough to
the to the week it's recognised as a
revolution but what it is is a strike
against Emperor so I think let us all be
honest let us simply say it is from this
moment that the movement towards
independence and gathers force there'll
be a terrible civil war but it is from
that our stage has come having read
their Proclamation they were forced to
retreat to a row of houses on Moore
Street James Connelly was one of those
leading the uprising for his
great-grandson James these cobbled
streets are sacred ground we have here
what is in effect the birthplace of the
Republic where volunteers made their
last stand in 1916 so the 1916 rising
effect effectively ended in this very
area that we're standing in today and
most of the buildings that we have here
including the streets and laneways are
as they we're in 1916
but there's nowhere more sacred to Irish
Republicans than kill me annum jail
leaders of the uprising spent their
final hours in these cells they seemed
destined to become a footnote in history
until Britain made a disastrous decision
16 of them were executed 14 by firing
squad in the stone breakers yard here it
turned the tide of public opinion in
Ireland when the British ruthlessly
cannon killed the leaders they quite
deliberately took the head off their
evolution the thinkers and philosophers
were removed obviously it was unarmed
raising but it was more than that you
know it was at a time when the British
had the largest empire in the history of
humanity the small group of men and
women came together and and said it was
a better way of ordering our society
the proclamation would be read far and
wide the rising made the front page of
the New York Times for 14 consecutive
days and part inspired the Russian
Revolution a year later all changed
changed utterly a terrible beauty is
born in the words of the poet it was a
arising of poets and artists and
dramatists and the whole idea of it
being staged in the hope that the Irish
would be able to get to the negotiation
table to put their case for their
independence and I suppose it was
aspirational and it was full of hope but
it was also a new generation so many of
the young people that were there were
young and idealistic two years after the
Easter Rising Shin fan won a landslide
victory Ireland voted for the aims of
the rebellion a republic rather than the
home rule which had already been agreed
one former Irish prime minister says
there was no need for an armed uprising
there's an ambivalence in this sense and
the people are saying well it's not
justified to use the gun now but we are
going to justify it's being used in the
past now in my view it was wrong on both
occasions 1916 was unnecessary
we had Home Rule already there was no
need for violence it didn't meet the
criteria at the 1916 rebellion of a just
war it was not necessary
in her historic state visit to Dublin
Britain's Queen honored Ireland's dead
Her Majesty paid her respects to those
who had taken part in the Easter Rising
but Northern Ireland's First Minister
the Democratic Unionist leader won't be
attending any commemoration I think the
queen is a beacon of reconciliation and
she's been seen as such particularly in
Northern Ireland because of the way in
which she has conducted herself there
for many years for me as a unionist as
somebody who has lived through the
troubles in Northern Ireland were
frankly the Easter Rising was used as a
justification for the legitimacy of what
actually occurred during those 35 to 40
years it's something I don't see as
fitting of official commemoration do I
accept that it happened of course it
happened and it's very much part of what
happened on this island what I didn't
see fit to commemorate it in an official
way 485 people died in the rebellion
most of them civilians nearly 1,600 were
wounded was there an alternative to an
armed uprising Ireland's head of state
says the events of Easter 1916 must be
viewed in a wide context well I think to
understand arising and a response to it
you have to understand more than the
nationalist tendencies that were being
discussed all the time maybe the most
challenging is to discuss the mind of
Empire it is the character of the
response to the rising and the
executions the imprisonment the huge
building up of scale to crush the rising
the great significance of my that when I
would with the state visit to the United
Kingdom um a mission of Queen Elizabeth
was the atmosphere which was wonderful
in a way because a Majesty had had a
head very clearly in her visit to
Ireland and struck a huge chord with the
recognition that in respecting this
complexity and difference is so
important if we're where we are so that
our present isn't in fact carrying any
legacies of Biggers and certainly so
that the future we can embrace it
together there are those of course who
would fear that commemorating an armed
rising is a dangerous thing to do in
modern Ireland what are your thoughts on
that I don't agree with this at all the
most useless thing I think is to effect
some kind of amnesia and amnesia
wouldn't work I remember when I became
president for us going to Northern
Ireland preparing my speeches and I
would regard it as immoral to actually
say to somebody you must put it all
behind you how can you if you're the
member of your family in a wheelchair
somebody's lost a limb or a loved one
has been been murdered or whatever you
you really have to if you're involved in
the ethics of memory you have to
transact us so therefore you recognize
it and you look at the complexity and
that's the new must be open to the
different narratives that must be placed
side by side
police in Northern Ireland are concerned
that dissident republicans will seek to
exploit the centenary detectives are
already investigating the murder of a
prison officer who was fatally wounded
when a bomb exploded beneath his van in
Belfast there are people within
dissident republican groupings who want
the mark the Easter 2016 hundredth
anniversary and an entirely more
sinister way who want to kill police
officers present officers or soldiers so
we believe the threat is extremely high
at the moment it's at the upper end of
severe and we need community support
executed for the murder of a policeman
in 1916 Thomas Kent was granted a state
funeral last year his remains had been
exhumed from a prison in Cork right
Highgate not for some the rebellion was
a glorious episode in history for others
the ingredients were far too toxic and
incendiary to be commemorated to some
extent that willingness our want to keep
the violent tradition alive derives
directly from the fact that we have
overly celebrated the violent tradition
in Irish politics and the Irish state
has to enjoy extent in my opinion
celebrations the violent traditional
Irish politics and downgraded the
constitutional peaceful achievements of
Home Rule and reformed the universities
the educational system all those things
that were done without the use of
violence over time the facts became
blurred the Easter Rising would be used
by those attempting to legitimize
violence but Ireland is reclaiming its
history to the pride of those whose
families participated in the rebellion
I'm extremely proud because I believe
that they they did something that they
felt was good for everybody not just for
themselves and they paid a huge price
there were a lot of different groups
involved with slightly different agendas
but they all came together in that they
wanted change relatives of the rising
are engaged in their own battle
they are campaigning to have more street
protected it's where their ancestors
took their last stand
the man who were the first signatories
to the proclamation of the Irish
Republic where stands the Republic for
which they gave their lives I mean I
think the principles contained in the
proclamation of the Republic to which
they signed up to are still very
relevant to the issues that we face
today we have an opportunity now in
centenary year to reflect on that and to
attempt to start out to build the sort
of Republic for which they gave their
lives
Dublin still bears the scars among them
a bullet hole in the breast of the angel
on O'Connell Street Ireland had to wait
for independence but one momentous week
a hundred years ago would forever be
etched on the collective memory of this
nation there will always be those who
attempt to use the Easter Rising for
political ends even those who seek to
justify violence the challenge is to
ensure that this commemoration becomes
an impetus to pace for despite the
complexities of their shared history
there is a new relationship between
Britain and Ireland it may have taken
the best part of a century but things
have changed changed utterly
you